Gotham's grand finale will be no joke.
A teaser trailer and character poster for
the series' final episode depict criminal
mastermind Jeremiah Valeska in full-on Joker
Mode.
It's highly unlikely he'll be referred to
as The Joker, but the promo materials leave
little doubt as to the fact that Jeremiah
will embrace his own destiny as the Clown
Prince of Crime during the 10-year time jump
which will see Bruce Wayne, played by David
Mazouz, take on the mantle of Batman.
At least a portion of Gotham's final episode
will take place after that decade-long jump.
As the spot, tellingly titled "J," opens,
there's Wayne Enterprises tower, looming over
a dark Gotham City as the tinkling strains
of Julie Andrews' "I Feel Pretty" glide over
the soundtrack.
This gives way to a shot of Arkham Asylum.
Inside its gates a seated figure with stringy,
patchy hair, remains still as the inmates
mill around in slow motion.
Then, we see his face: it's Jeremiah Valeska,
played by Cameron Monaghan, looking worse
for wear after years presumably spent inside.
"I feel something new.
Something beautiful."
There's very familiar-sounding cackle over
the title card, followed by a brief shot of
Jeremiah looking at his own hand, impaled
by a Batarang, with a mixture of alarm and
amusement.
He bursts into hysterical laughter as the
spot ends.
Jeremiah is clearly meant to be a version
of the Joker, if not necessarily the Joker.
Fans have been engaged in back-and-forth debate
about whether Jeremiah, and before him, his
psychopathic twin brother Jerome would ever
become Gotham's iteration of the character,
a debate which was seemingly laid to rest
when Monaghan tweeted a series of photos and
videos from the makeup chair in May 2018.
According to the actor, not only is he not
playing the Joker, but the show is prohibited
by Warner Brothers from using the character
in any way.
Executive producer John Stephens even flatly
stated as much himself in a conversation with
IGN later that year, saying,
The real Joker, Stephens says, is out there,
taking his cues from proto-Jokers including
Jeremiah, Jerome, and others.
Stephens then seemed to at least partially
walk back his comments in a GameSpot interview
in March 2019.
Stephens added that there are still other
traits of the Joker's personality, such as
being "actually a nightmare," that the Gotham
writers had yet to explore.
This version of the maybe-Joker may fit that
bill.
He has a look nearly as terrifying as Heath
Ledger's iconic interpretation in The Dark
Knight, and that chilling laugh is indeed
the stuff of nightmares.
One can't help but feel that Fox is basically
doing an end run, sticking to the letter of
Warner Brothers' mandate while finding a way
to pair Batman, who is finally making his
appearance on Gotham after five seasons and
99 episodes, with his nemesis.
With the final episode, fans will finally
get to see Mazouz in action as the Caped Crusader,
or at least his face digitally pasted onto
the body of a much more physically imposing
stand-in, opposed by a very Joker-like villain.
Stephens and company can insist that Jeremiah
is just a prototype Joker who happened to
have fallen into a vat of toxic chemicals
in the exact same manner as Jack Nicholson's
Joker in Tim Burton's Batman.
And that he just happens to look, sound, and
act exactly like the criminal who he will
inspire with his maniacal ways at some undetermined
point in a future Gotham will never show.
Evidently, Warner Brothers' brass are buying
it, but that doesn't mean viewers have to.
Gotham's penultimate episode, "They Did What?"
airs on April 18; the finale, "The Beginning…"
follows April 25.
Mark your calendars.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Batman
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.